l'histoire de moto guzzi et l'aventuré
extraordinaire d'une idée et de la force
d'une entreprise qui a contribué à
ornans de l'italie à l'étranger
moto guzzi n'est à mandello del lario en
1921 de l'imagination de carlo gozzi
aujourd'hui encore si la marque de moto
italienne la plus célèbre moto guzzi
possède trois caractéristiques
extraordinaires
la fonctionnalité la beauté et le
pragmatisme
d'avoir su réunir toutes ces qualités en
une seule marque fait de ces motos des
mythes qui bravent le temps tout en
assurant la longévité de la marque
l'histoire commence donc à partir d'une
idée le concept de la moto guzzi n'est
pendant la première guerre mondiale
il n'est dans la tête d'un jeune
militaire milanais de l'armée de l'air
carlo good
il transmet à deux de ses amis
giovanni mirabel lit un coureur de
motocyclettes de brescia et giorgio
parodie un pilote
l'idée de construire une motocyclette
révolutionnaire
ainsi l'idée de la société se concrétisa
et à chacun fut confié une tâche à la
fin de la guerre carlo gozzi
peaufinerait la fabrication du prototype
ravel lee qui était déjà un pilote
expérimenté conduirait à la victoire le
nouvel engin et parodies garantir l
apport des capitaux nécessaires à
l'entreprise
c'est pendant les derniers jours de
guerre dans un accident de vol que
giovanni mirabelli décéda ne restait
possible comme associé que goody et
parodies ils pensèrent honorer le
souvenir de l'ami en utilisant dans la
marque le symbole de l'aigle
carlo gozzi fabrica n'ont qu'un
prototype et après approbation de la
famille parodie il fut décidé de
commencer la fabrication en série
le premier modèle moto guzzi sa peau la
normale sur son réservoir il y avait un
aigle et l'inscription moto guzzi le
moteur était à 4 temps monocylindre hic
horizontale avec 4 soupapes opposés et
500 centimètres cubes de cylindrée les
caractéristiques de ce premier moteur
resteront les mêmes avec peu de
modifications dans la production de moto
guzzi pendant de nombreuses années ce
qui assure à l'entreprise la réputation
de sérieux dans la fabrication et
d'honnêteté qui auréole encore cette
marque de nos jours la première moto de
carlo gozzi fut la normale une moto
révolutionnaire par certains aspects
révolutionnaire pourquoi parce qu'elle
synthétise est toutes les innovations et
les perfectionnements des motos de
l'époque mais en réalité l'idée de
goodies imed était de créer une machine
dont pourrait profiter tous ceux qui
n'étaient pas encore convaincus par ce
mode de déplacement
bien qu'il existe depuis 20 ans lusine
fut installé à mandello del lario
avant la moto guzzi mondello n'était
certainement pas une ville riche
l'entreprise goody il y a apporté une
nouvelle activité en donnant du travail
à beaucoup de familles à l'intérieur de
la ville mais aussi à l'extérieur sous
la poussée de la moto guzzi beaucoup
d'entreprises grandes et petites sont
nés et au fil des années elles se sont
développées en procurant du travail à
tous je me souviens de tous les ouvriers
qui sortait ou qui allait au travail à
pied ou en vélo
à cette époque là les routes demande des
lots n'était pas goudronnées le soir ils
sortaient ensemble pour aller chez eux
et le matin ils partaient ensemble avec
le sac pour la cantine qui contenait la
gamelle dessous
les salariés avaient la possibilité
d'acheter une grande variété de produits
au magasin de moto guzzi à des prix
avantageux pour les enfants il y avait
la colonie de vacances pour l'été c'est
bien fait se transformer en économie
d'argent déjà en 1921
grâce à la détermination de giorgio
parodie on décida de faire participer
les nouvelles motos aux premières
courses afin d'avoir un vecteur
publicitaire pour lancer la marque
les résultats furent immédiat et la
production moto guzzi commença à se
diversifier
l'idée gagnante 20 du frère de carlo
gozzi giuseppe surnommé ma coquille
était ingénieur
carlo et lui conçu une solution
innovante afin de régler le problème de
l'amortissement de la roue arrière
la solution se démontera tellement bonne
qu'elle fut à l'origine de la toute
première moto grand tourisme de
l'histoire avec cette moto n'a koffi des
voyages extraordinaires pour l'époque
elle fut commercialisé sous le nom de gt
mais le public la connaissais en tant
que norme g un surnom dérivé d'un des
raids de naco vers le pôle nord
en effet quelques années auparavant
le dirigeable norge et devint célèbre
parce que umberto nobile avait survolé
l'alaska avec pour atteindre le pôle
nord
entre temps la moto avec le réservoir
sous la selle paraissait déjà bien trop
vieille la guzzi aborda le problème en
1931 en sortant un modèle devenu célèbre
peut-être le plus classique avant la
seconde guerre mondiale le modèle sport
15 celle ci fut donc la plus populaire
parmi les moto guzzi d'avant-guerre son
succès résidait dans sa robustesse et sa
simplicité
la sport 15 subi au fil des années
plusieurs changements qui aboutira la
version grand tourisme gt 16 et j'étais
17 dans des versions conçues surtout
pour les courses
entre-temps en 1933 carlo gozzi
développa un moteur en v à deux soupapes
en tête et quatre vitesses qui fut à
l'origine des séries gtv et j'étais w
il s'agissait d'une évolution de l'idh
est primordial de la normale mais
permettait à la moto des performances
nouvelle celle ci allait donner
naissance au plus grand de motos
routières de compétition effectivement
dès 1921 la moto guzzi participa aux
courses et les résultats ne se firent
pas attendre
tenant compte des premières courses moto
guzzi fut convaincu que les courses et
est le meilleur vecteur publicitaire à
adopter pour l'image de la marque
cardo goody commence à étudier des motos
de compétition plus performantes
c'est ainsi que la moto de course bozzi
c'est devait ville jour comparativement
au modèle normal elle avait les deux
soupapes en tête et peu d'autres
variations lacets devait était une bonne
deux roues toutefois tout en remportant
des succès dans les épreuves de fond
elle n'était pas à même de faire face
aux adversaires dans les épreuves sur
circuit carnot goody pensa donc à
modifier le prototype qui avait donné
naissance à la normale et construisit un
moteur à 4 soupapes la c4 v venait de
naître
cette moto à 4 soupapes conduite par
guido matt asti devint célèbre pour
avoir gagné en 1924 à monza le
championnat d'europe
cette moto à 4 soupapes conduite par
guido matt asti devint célèbre pour
avoir gagné en 1924 à monza le
championnat d'europe
il courut avec une boîte à trois
vitesses sans le frein avant
il sent le levier de commande
les quatre soupapes marchait bien mais
guzzi n'avait rien à proposer dans les
catégories inférieures
en 1925 carlo gozzi décida donc de
tenter sa chance avec un moteur de 250
cm cube
cela donna naissance à la 250 qui
restera pendant environ trente ans une
des plus célèbres moto de course
gagnante de tous les temps
dans son palmarès elle peut faire état
de trois championnats du monde de seize
victoires en grand prix de cette
victoire au tourist trophy et de
nombreuses autres courses
chevauchant sa 250 corsa homobono teny
gagna le tourist trophy en 1937
ce fut le premier coureur non
britannique à réussir dans cette
compétition et cela fit sensation
s'il est vrai que la moto guzzi fut en
1935 la première marque non britannique
à gagner le tourist trophy homobono teny
fut le premier pilote non britannique a
gagné la plus célèbre et ancienne course
du monde
en suscitant chez le public britannique
un enthousiasme absolument
extraordinaire on l'appelait black devil
le diable noir il rentra en italie et
fut accueillie dans cette révision attal
d'une manière triomphale
après un passage obligatoire à mondello
homobono tennis peut-être considéré
comme le valentino rossi des années 30
malgré la faible couverture média de
l'époque il devint très populaire à son
propos est née une légende de pilotes
très agressif faisant corps unique avec
sa moto qui frôlait les murs au point
d'avoir la combinaison toujours plein de
gravats tombait souvent mais se relever
reprenons la course si c'était possible
il était très célèbre à cause de sa
tignasse comme valentino qui a longtemps
joué lui aussi de sa chevelure
il fut consacrée comme pilote symbole de
la maison demande
le destin donna rendez-vous à homobono
teny sur un circuit suisse dans la
banlieue de berne
témoin de quelques-uns de ces grands
exploits ce jour là pendant l'épreuve
il n'était pas satisfait de sa goody 250
avec laquelle il aurait dû mener la
compétition il voulu effectuer encore un
tour d'essai il partit l'asphalté
mouillé il dérape a fuit un vol plané et
se fracassa contre un arbre le destin a
voulu que peu d'heures après un autre
grand pilote trouva la mort en voiture
l'émotion suscitée par les deux morts
fut énorme homobono teny fut accompagnée
par une foule énorme depuis mindelo où
se trouvait la chapelle ardente jusqu à
trévise où l'on célébrait ses
funérailles
le cercueil dans le camion de
l'entreprise moto guzzi fit un voyage à
étapes demande des lots à trévise au
cours duquel beaucoup de représentants
des motos clubs locaux vont dire chômage
at any
on
la moto quatre soupapes n'était plus
concurrentiel surtout comparé aux motos
anglaises
c'est alors que carlo gozzi ayant eu de
grandes satisfactions avec le modèle de
la 250 qui avait gagné toutes les
courses de sa catégorie assembla deux
moteurs créa la 500 naquit la bi
cylindre et glorieuse qui est entré dans
l'histoire grâce aux exploits de bandini
et de balsa rôti
l'expérience acquise par goody dans le
secteur des courses de deux cent
cinquante centimètres cubes fut à
l'origine des essais avec une cylindrée
moindre pour les motos routières la 175
peine à kipé signifiant petit ont conçu
une petite moto de 175 centimètres cubes
qui fut introduite sur le marché
en 1933 c'était un chef-d'oeuvre de
simplicité d'esthétique et de robustesse
ensuite juste avant la guerre cette moto
fut amélioré le moteur de vingt deux
cent cinquante centimètres cubes à
quatre vitesses
il s'agissait de l'iphone décliner
ensuite en version de tourisme et de
sport la production de l'iphone se
poursuivit jusqu'en 1957
ce qui fit de cette moto là deux roues
italienne de moyenne cylindrée la plus
répandue pendant plus de 15 ans elle
représentait un bon compromis entre une
citadine et une moto plus performant
le fascisme mis sur pied des courses
pour ses policiers
ces combattants les motos étaient les
mêmes pour tous en 1939 de la gtc sorti
le modèle condor
l'hôtel le public sportif des courses
dès 1939 pu profiter du condor pour la
catégorie 500 dans la catégorie 250
giulio cesare carcano prépare à
l'albatros
entre temps la deuxième guerre mondiale
approchait ce qui signifie à
l'interruption des courses et la
reconversion de l'entreprise pour la
production militaire
l'entreprise guzzi avait toujours un
rapport privilégié avec l'armée en effet
avant la guerre elle avait équipé
l'armée de la gt 17 une évolution de la
nage
elle fabrique à les deux motos les plus
utilisés pendant la guerre l'alsh et et
la super alger
à la fin de la guerre chez gucci rénover
la production était impératif il fallait
fabriquer de nouveaux engins capables de
donner de l'élan à l'entreprise et de
plus tout un pays était à motoriser
la renaissance de l'italie s'est fait
sur les deux roues des cyclomoteurs
guzzi lee a largement participé temps
avec ces motocyclettes légères qu'avec
ses triporteur à moteur qui ont apporté
au pays la mobilité nécessaire à la
reconstruction le transport des
marchandises sur des moyens de transport
des rives et des motocyclettes avait
déjà été conçu avant la guerre avec des
triporteurs à moteur 500 aussi pratique
que simple
parmi ces derniers il y avait le loup et
le célèbre école
l'italie qui sortait de la tragédie que
la guerre avait besoin de moyens de
transport rapide
on se souvient de la vespa mais la guzzi
aussi jouent un rôle important
le premier motocycles légers qui sortit
de lusine demande des lots fut le 65
appelé goudineau par la suite pendant
ses trois premières années d'existence
il fut produit à cinquante mille unités
il avait un moteur 2 temps monocylindre
hic incliné qui n'assurait pas une
grande performance mais possédait les
qualités habituelles de solidité des
moteurs guzzi
après le goût dit non ce fut le gall et
os conçu par carlo gozzi en 1950
il mariait les avantages d'une moto
classique arroux haute aux
caractéristiques d'un scooter conçu avec
un moteur à quatre temps
sa cylindrée de 2 centimètres cubes lui
assurer de bonnes performances
mais il fallait concevoir également des
modèles de cylindrée supérieure étant
donné que les motos utilisées étaient
encore celle de l'avant guerre on
relance à la gtv elle devint grâce à
quelques modifications
l'ast aurait suivi par un modèle plus
évolué le falcon qui fut l'un des
modèles les plus représentatifs de la
marque guzzi mais en quelques années les
motos commencèrent à perdre du terrain
remplacé par des voitures de petites
cylindrées qui assurait une plus grande
stabilité moins de risques d'un très bon
confort à des prix concurrentiels
les courses de l'après guerre surtout
depuis 1949 quand on a créé le premier
championnat du monde de vitesse sur le
théâtre de rivalités technique entre les
différentes maisons
nombreuses étaient les protagonistes
italienne dit les reins mv mais aussi
mondiale benelli et bien évidemment moto
guzzi les étrangères était surtout
anglaise et allemande guzzi fera pas
très fort avec la mono cylindre bialbero
qui gagne à 5 fois le championnat du
monde
parallèlement après la guerre les
courses recommençait rappelé un rythme
les années de 46 à 50 7 représente le
point culminant de l'histoire des
courses de moto guzzi
entre temps à l' usine un service course
géré par giulio cesare car kahn avait
été adjoint aux services de conception
de carlo gouttes
carcano avec la collaboration de comptes
tony et de taux zéro et le créateur de
quelques-unes des plus extraordinaires
moto de course de tous les tentes il
conçu également des modifications sur
les moteurs encore valable de nos jours
le service course juste après la guerre
pouvait encore compter sur le condor et
ses transformations son évolution direct
fut le don de dominos dont le nom est
évoqué une tenue de route médiocre en
revanche sa vitesse atteignait 170
km/heure
fini en effet ce projet étant terminée
nous avons commencé en 1946 à préparer
le modèle gamba longue un dérivé du
condor et du domp doline
le moteur du dondo lino transformé en
celui du combat lunga avait la corsa
lung par rapport aux dandoli non il
était toujours 1 500 mais on avait
réduit le diamètre en augmentant la
course
c'est pourquoi on lui a affublé le
sobriquet corsa loong
et pour cette raison on l'a surnommé
gamba lung accompagna le succès de
nombreux pilotes dont ferdinando
balzaretti je suis le fils de ferdinand
d'obala rôti pilotes officiels moto
guzzi et ensuite essayer nos moteurs
jusqu'en 1968 terminer la période de la
guerre
les courses ont recommencé
mon père a piloté la gomme balloune gars
et puis a continué avec les gamba
lunghini il s'est arrêté en 1949 à cause
d'un accident
je me souviens que les tours d'essai
était différent par rapport à
aujourd'hui
mon père sortait avec la moto dans les
rues le samedi les garçons sortaient des
bars pour lui dégager la route et de
faire passer
je me souviens qu ils m'emmenaient aux
courses
moi j'attendais impatiemment ce moment
parce que lorsqu'il gagnait il me
faisait faire le tour avec lui sur le
réservoir de la moto les fleurs et la
coupe à la main c'était des moments
émouvants dont je me souviens encore
aujourd'hui
dans le but d'améliorer les performances
moto guzzi s'étaient équipés dès le
début des années 50 d'une extraordinaire
nouveautés techniques la soufflerie
aérodynamique
ce fut donc la première entreprise
motocyclistes italienne a étudié à fond
l'aérodynamique et à exploiter
complètement les modifications du cadre
afin d'augmenter la vitesse
carcano propose à goody la possibilité
d'essayer les motos dans une soufflerie
aérodynamique
on pouvait y tester avec le pilote
la résistance du véhicule à l'air et
guzzi accueilli l'idée avec enthousiasme
la soufflerie servait à mieux voir où
travailler les modifications du véhicule
c'est ainsi qu'on a créé le carénage à
cloche
la préparation des véhicules de course
et un travail long et précis qui n'est
jamais tout à fait terminée l'équipe s'y
consacre donc avec un total d vous mon
père a toujours travaillé au service
course et a vécu la vraie vie des
ouvriers
une vie faite de déplacement on
s'activait beaucoup à faire
même quand on était pas en voyage pour
suivre des courses il répare lé moteur
entre deux courses
les courses était très dangereuse et se
dérouler plus souvent sur route que sur
circuit la course sur route en la plus
célèbre était depuis les années 20 le
raid nord-sud qui devint ensuite le
milan 40 mille 400 km de routes
épuisante sur lesquels moto guzzi gagna
souvent agostini remporta une grande
victoire
ce qui lui permis d'entrer de plein
droit dans l'équipe moto guzzi
dans la catégorie 250 lorenzetti avait
proposé des modifications sur l'albatros
ce fut l'origine du gamba lounguine haut
en 1953
on décida de participer également aux
courses dans la catégorie 350 à
l'étranger en modifiant le gamba
lounguine haut on arrive à un moteur des
as et es350 qui remporta cinq titres
mondiaux
on
progresser ça veut dire créer si on
repense ces années-là concevoir une moto
nouvelle c'était l'assurance de gagner
sur les pistes en tant qu ingénieur de
projet je sentais cette responsabilité
lourde est important j'avais à démontrer
que mes idées étaient bonnes et la
réalité m'a donné raison
l'a350 a remporté cinq titres mondiaux
mais les adversaires commençaient à se
tailler une place dans la catégorie
reine des courses
gilera avait acquis une longue
expérience dans le domaine des multi
cylindrée le groupe formé par carcano
taux des roues et qu'anthony ceux remis
au travail
il crée alors un engin extraordinaire la
v8
vous
oui
je
la v8 a été reconnue comme la moto la
plus extraordinaire jamais produite
et je continue à le penser
l'ingénieur cesari carcano un véritable
génie créa c'est huit-cylindres qui
avait un empattement réduit 50 cm de
largeur une nuit cylindres mais enlevés
avec quatre cylindres vers l'avant et
quatre à l'arrière
tout a été fait en six mois du projet à
l'essai du moteur carcano todéro et
qu'anthony on était bouche bée il ne
réalisait pas que cette moto qui venait
d'être créée je pouvais donner 70
chevaux
douze mille tours minute sans aucun
problème sur ceux liés à l'allumage et à
la carburation
c'est un moteur qui ne donne pas la
sensation de vitesse il ne vibre pas il
n'est pas c'est comme un monocylindre
donc on ne sent pas la vitesse ni avec
les mains ni avec les fesses comme
disent les pilotes on s'aperçoit de la
vitesse quand on sort la tête du
carénage le moteur peut atteindre 300 km
heure c'était la veille de pâques on
avait porté le moteur dans la salle pour
l'essayer et on espérait que tout se
passerait bien
quand le mécanicien a mis en marche
la moto a démarré ça a été une joie pour
tous
on a envoyé un télégramme à gènes
puisque le siège de l'entreprise se
trouvaient là et mathieu giorgio parodie
a transmis ce matin à 10h30
le huit cylindres a vécu ses premières
minutes
la v8 cette moto extraordinaire a eu un
destin malchanceux parce qu'il
s'agissait d'une machine complexe qui
avait besoin d'être bien essayer d'être
bien développé sa vie a été courte
elle a débuté en 1955 et en 1957
moto guzzi a adhéré au pacte des maisons
italiennes qui prévoyait un retrait des
courses
le v8 est resté au garage destiné au
musée comme exemple d'une technologie
absolument extraordinaire
en 1957
moto guzzi arrête les courses de vitesse
en revanche on entreprend des courses de
régularité qui pour nous était quelque
chose de nouveau
le règlement prévoyait d'utiliser les
motos de série légèrement modifié nous
on a participé avec la 125 et la 250
l'histoire des compétitions d'endurance
est longue et pleine de succès des moto
guzzi le travail du service projets
trouva sa prolongation dans la
conception de motos citadine il existait
des versions du falcon pour les
militaires et pour la police mais dans
le milieu des années 60 ces motos
étaient suranné trop petit pour lutter
dans un marché où les grosses motos
commençait à s'imposer
carcano me donc au point le moteur qui
est encore de nos jours à la base de la
production guzzi levé 7
l'armée a sollicité moto guzzi pour que
soit créé quelque chose de plus grand et
moto guzzi à fabriquer ce chef-d'oeuvre
qui est levé 7
le modèle qui a vécu le plus longtemps
donc on a dépassé ce qui avait été créée
par carlo goods ce modèle a été conçu
par carcano est réalisé avec la
collaboration de taux zéro et de contenu
le moteur v 7 qui vit le jour entre 1964
et 1965 était bicylindre très loin de
l'idée de carlo gozzi qui jusqu'à
maintenant avait assuré le succès de la
marque
ce fut le dernier projet de carcano car
après 1966 il interrompit ses relations
avec l'entreprise
d'ailleurs à cette époque moto guzzi se
trouvait dans une situation très
difficile
à tel point qu'en 1966 la firme fut
soumise au régime de gestion contrôlé
puis cédée à same petit tout en
travaillant dans une situation d'urgence
su mener à une très bonne politique de
gestion d'entreprise saïfi d'excellents
choix dans la production et exploiter au
maximum le nouveau moteur
à partir du v7 ont vu le jour tous les
modèles bicylindre en v
les 350 les 500 mais aussi les 900 les
1200 et ses produits actuellement la v7
eu donc d'abord utilisé dans un but
militaire adoptée par la police
italienne
cette moto suscita bientôt un très grand
intérêt à l'étranger la police
californienne l'a choisi pour son amour
et patrol et goody choisi d'en produire
une version civile qui fut exposée pour
la première fois au salon de milan en
les ventes en italie débutèrent elle en
bien reçus par le marché elle fut suivie
de la v7 spéciale une 750 cm cube puis
d'un autre mythe la guzzi v7 sport à
l'extraordinaire tenue de route et au
design moderne et attrayant j'ai essayé
les moto guzzi de 1966 à 1974 puis j'ai
recommencé en 1982 et je me sens honorée
d'avoir essayé la première v7 sport qui
après devenu une légende concurrencer
les firmes japonaises honda suzuki-
kawasaki sans aucun doute nous étions
celle qui avait créé la moto parfaite de
nombreux modèles s'inspirèrent de la
vaisselle d'origine grâce à l'expérience
de todéro et de l'hymne automne ti qui
était arrivé chez guzzi repris par same
on leur doit la création de cadres et de
la très belle ligne de ces motos le
marché américain
attirés par la technologie italienne fut
à l'initiative des versions spéciales
californien et ambassador les cruisers
italienne puissante et élégante
entrèrent de plain pied dans
l'imaginaire collectif
l'évolution de la v7 marqua la fin de
l'époque same et la compagnie fut cédée
à l'industriel des tommaso qu'il agira
avec des hauts et des bas jusqu'à l'an
2000 les ultimes évolution de la v7
furent la 850 le mans aux lignes nettes
et moderne et l'âme il y compte verte
créée afin de répondre aux besoins des
corps de police des états unis équipé
d'une boîte de vitesses automatique
en 2000 l'entreprise fut acheté par le
patron d'aprilia qui lança une nouvelle
recherche stylistique 2004 marque à un
temps d'arrêt quand l' usine de mandello
fut vendue au groupe piaggio il
produisit en peu de temps des version
renouvelée de modèles déjà connus ainsi
que de nouvelles motos qui aurait un
impact considérable
goody est une entreprise qui a
représenté pour l'industrie nationale
quelque chose de vraiment important et
qui a réussi à réunir tradition et
innovation
aujourd'hui goody produit des motos pour
une tranche restreinte de public plutôt
pour des passionnés
même si maintenant elle serait capable
de reconquérir des foules grâce
notamment à l'actuel diffusion de la
moto
la marque de l'aigle paraît avoir repris
son éclat en retrouvant le chemin de
leurs yeux des victoires sportives la
moto guzzi semble donc bien parti pour
reprendre avec entrain et rapidement son
aventure sur la voie tracée auparavant
par une poignée d'hommes courageux et
clairvoyant
guidés par carlo gozzi et giorgio parole
oh
e
mon
et